préfecture
k
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
même style
on est en approche
grippé
notre convoi attention à 4
au revoir ces gamins et en difficulté
dégage
mollo sur la haine thanos
le protégerait contre câble est tout
seul je peux pas faut du renfort
on va former un super méga groupe on va
refaire un tour sur linkedin
je me présente date là je m'appelle
shatter star
domino j'ai de la chance et la chance
c'est pas super pouvoir écouter sinon ça
ne fait pas
mais si on n'a qu'à couper la poire en
deux et non aller en piste donc
comment
et
c'est qui ces enchevêtrements d'arc
tu es sûr que tu viens pas l'univers dc
comics
le
[Musique]
willy deux parties
dis donc t'es balles elles sont rapides
maintenant pour couronner le tout peter
un super pouvoir quelconque je sais pas
nager pas de pouvoir non j'ai vu
l'annoncé voilà tel poste
[Musique]